was nun folgt ist eine wahre Geschichte
Patientin 230 verstarb am 22 Juli diesen
Jahres im Alter von 82 Jahren in einem
Krankenhaus hier in Deutschland zu
Lebzeiten hatte sie arrangieren lassen
was nun folgte ihr Blut wurde gegen eine
Lösung mit gefrierschutzmitteln
ausgetauscht und ihr Körper auf
Trockeneis gelegt man holte die
Genehmigungen ein um sie aus der Landes
zu schaffen und am 9 august um 13 Uhr
landete die Patienten am Detroit Metro
Airport von dort wurde sie zum cryonics
Institute transportiert wo sie in einer
Kühlkammer über einen Zeitraum von 39
Stunden auf
-196°c heruntergekühlt wurde die
Temperatur von flüssigem Stickstoff
seitdem liegt ihr Körper in einem
Computer gesteuerten Kühlschrank und
hofft darauf irgendwann wiederbelebt zu
werden
Patientin 230 ist eine von über 500
Menschen die sich von einem der vier
größten Anbieter für Kryonik haben
einfrieren lassen dabei sagt selbst das
troyonics Institute dass es sich hierbei
um eine Wette handelt
eine Wette auf die
medizinisch-technischen Möglichkeiten
der Zukunft und wir haben uns gefragt
wird sich diese Wette lohnen werden
diese Menschen jemals wieder aufwachen
und wenn nicht wie könnten wir es
vielleicht doch schaffen Menschen
erfolgreich einzufrieren und in der
Zukunft wieder zu leben
wenn wir als Menschheit andere Sterne
bereisen wollen ohne dass dabei
Generationen von Menschen auf
Raumschiffen leben und sterben dann
brauchen wir Kryonik aber auch schon
heute hier auf der Erde wäre sie extrem
praktisch stell dir vor du leidest jetzt
gerade an einer unheilbaren Krankheit
die aber in der Zukunft geheilt werden
könnte oder du willst wie ich z.B
unbedingt sehen ob es in 100 Jahren
fliegende Autos kalte Kernfusion und
Half-Life 3 geben wird hört sich geil an
dann musst du dich dafür umbringen
lassen denn einen lebenden Menschen
einzufrieren ist Mord es gibt noch keine
Methode einen eingefrorenen Menschen
sicher wiederzubeleben deshalb frieren
die kronikinstitute nur kürzlich
verstorbene Menschen ein und lagern sie
für die Zukunft eine Zukunft in der sie
hoffen dass man ihre Todesursache heilen
kann dabei gibt es zwei Varianten einmal
der ganze Körper wird eingefroren das
kostet bis zu 300.000 US Dollar oder
einmal nur der Kopf das ist zwar etwas
preisgünstiger dafür brauchen die
Patienten dann nach dem Auftauen aber
auch ein komplett neuen Körper oder
müssen sich mit einem Julia sagen wir
mal eher eingeschränkten Lebensstil
begnügen
ich bin wieder aufgewacht es hat
funktioniert aber bei mir zu kalt und
vielleicht hätte ich doch eher das etwas
teurere Paket wählen sollen so
das sind ja willkommen zurück das ist
übrigens die gute Nachricht wir konnten
sie erfolgreich Auftauen ich habe auch
für Sie noch eine schlechte Nachricht
und eine
sehr schlechte Nachricht die schlechte
Nachricht ist wir sind leider Opfer
eines man in the middle Angriffs
geworden und alle Ihre Daten wurden
geklaut und im Dark Web verkauft aber
das schlimmste ist wir konnten leider
ihre Lieblingsserie Gilmore Girls nicht
vorbereiten weil die seit 98 Jahren in
Deutschland nicht verfügbar ist und wir
kein VPN haben aber wie konnte das
passieren benutzen die keiner nordvpn
das schützt noch vor genau solchen
Angriffen und es hat auch noch einen
eingebauten dark Web Scanner gut dass
ich euch nicht mein Display Plus Account
gegeben habe jetzt steht da nicht so
Blut rum du kannst ja immerhin mein 2
Jahresabo abschließen dann passiert
sowas in Zukunft nicht mehr zu meiner
Zeit hat man dafür noch Doktor Watson
als Code eingegeben und immerhin 4
Monate gratis bekommen ach ja das waren
noch Zeiten
gerade mal ein paar Minuten am Leben und
schon solche Einfälle werden sie
wirklich früher Auftauen sollen also wir
haben jetzt ihren VPN aktiviert und die
Kontrolle zurück zu gewinnen und alle
Daten sind jetzt sicher und das beste
wir sie können jetzt endlich gucken
[ __ ] mich ohne mich an und 30 Tage Geld
zurück Garantie gibt's ja auch noch ich
muss los hallo ich bin noch hier was mit
mir ich will auch gehen
hallo
hört mich jemand das Geld brauchen die
Patienten natürlich nicht mehr sie sind
ja tot vielleicht denken sich einige
Kandidaten deshalb dass die Wette ja
nicht schaden könnte davon abgesehen
wettet man allerdings nicht nur auf den
medizinischen Fortschritt sondern auch
darauf dass die Firmen währenddessen
nicht pleite gehen oder einen sogar
versehentlich Auftauen beides ist schon
passiert
jedenfalls hoffen stand Anfang September
427 Patienten in den USA 87 in Russland
und eine unbekannte Anzahl in China auf
eine bessere Zukunft aber wie hoch sind
denn die Chancen dass diese Menschen
jemals wieder unbeschadet aufgetaut
werden können
nun es gibt Tiere die viele tausend
Jahre als Eiswürfel überlebt haben auch
einige Wirbeltiere überdauern jeden
Winter im gefrorenen Zustand aber warum
funktioniert das nicht bei uns Menschen
das Hauptproblem ist nicht das Auftauen
wie man vielleicht meinen könnte sondern
das Einfrieren denn das verursacht große
Schäden am Körper
die Probleme beim Einfrieren
Eiskristalle verletzen die Zellen
Membranen und zerstören so die Struktur
der Zelle nach dem Auftauen ist dann
alles Matsch wer schon mal eine Banane
eingefroren hat und dann wieder
aufgetaut hat der weiß wovon wir reden
deswegen kann man bisher nur kleine
einfach strukturierte Zellen unbeschadet
einfrieren Keimzellen zum Beispiel und
Embryonen wenn sie noch aus wenigen
einfachen Zellen besteht das braucht man
zum Beispiel in der Medizin Tiermedizin
Tier- und Pflanzenzucht und natürlich in
der biologischen Forschung um Schäden
durch Eiskristalle innerhalb der Zellen
zu verhindern werden die Zellen oder im
Regionen in einer Art Lösung überführt
die als Frostschutzmittel dient dabei
benötigen zum Beispiel Spermien und
Eizellen unterschiedliche
einfrierprotokolle Eizellen werden
Schock gefroren Spermien können dagegen
vergleichsweise langsam heruntergekühlt
werden es liegt an der unterschiedlichen
Größe Eizellen sind groß und rund
Spermien klein und dünnen bei komplexen
Zellen wie Neuronen haben wir aber
sowohl dünne Fortsätze als auch dicke
Zellkörper deshalb funktioniert hier
keine der beiden Methoden so richtig und
noch schwieriger wird es wenn man für
die Transplantation Chirurgie ganz so
Organe einfrieren möchte denn die
bestehen ja aus vielen verschiedenen
Zelltypen mit unterschiedlichen behalten
außerdem ist es schwieriger das
Frostschutzmittel in alle Zellen zu
bekommen und auch nachher wieder
rauszubekommen und für einen ganzen
Menschen verschärft sich diese
Problematik natürlich nur noch weiter na
gut es gibt also kein gutes
einfrierverfahren für Menschen sich
heute einfrieren zu lassen ist also
eigentlich nicht so schlau aber
vielleicht ändert sich das ja in der
Zukunft für solche Methoden
interessieren sich nämlich nicht nur ein
paar Kryonik Anwärter sondern auch die
Transplantationsmedizin
spendeorgane über lange Zeit lagern zu
können würde vielen Menschen das Leben
retten also was muss man bei der
kryonikforschung alles beachten wie
macht man aus etwas das heute Mord wäre
eine sichere Zukunftstechnologie genau
das könnte uns ein spannendes Tier
zeigen dass sich jedes Jahr freiwillig
einfrieren lässt der nordamerikanische
Waldfrosch
wenn sich die Temperaturen im Herbst dem
Gefrierpunkt nähern versteckt sich der
Frosch unter Laub dort wo Eis seine
durchläss laut berührt bilden sich die
ersten Eiskeime unter der Haut sinkt die
Körpertemperatur unter -2,5 Grad Celsius
dann friert das Wasser in seinem Körper
von außen nach innen bis zu 70% des
Wassers werden zu Eis es bildet sich
zwischen der Haut und den Skelettmuskeln
und in den flüssigkeitsgefüllten
Hohlräumen der Blase des Gehirns und
sogar in den Augen nur das Wasser im
Inneren der Zellen bleibt flüssig Herz
Lunge Nervensystem alles steht still im
Grunde genommen ist der Frosch nun tot
erst im Frühling taut er wieder auf
zuerst kommt der Herzschlag zurück dann
die Atmung und schließlich
nervenreaktionen und Reflexe nach nur 12
Stunden ist der Frosch wieder lebendig
ohne messbaren schaden also genau das
was wir uns für unsere Pronomic
Patienten auch wünschen deshalb lohnt es
sich hier genauer hinzuschauen also wie
überlebt der Waldfrosch
auch der Frosch verwendet ein
Frostschutzmittel sobald das erste Eis
im Körper entsteht produziert seine
Leber große Mengen an Glukose Herz und
Körperzellen arbeiten auf Hochtouren um
den Zucker sich schnell wie möglich in
die Organe zu bringen in wenigen Minuten
steigt seine Konzentration in den
zentralen Organen auf das Achtfache nach
einigen Stunden erreicht sie sogar das
60-fache Glukose ist als
froschschutzmittel natürlich praktisch
weil sie ohnehin schon im Körper
hergestellt transportiert und umgesetzt
wird das macht Glucose auch weniger
giftig als andere Chemikalien außerdem
kann sie auch Proteine stabilisieren
allerdings können bei extrem hohen
glukosekonzentrationen auch Giftstoffe
entstehen gegen die der Frosch sich mit
antioxidantien schützen muss aber
Glukose als Frostschutzmittel ist nicht
die einzige Anpassung die wir finden so
bekämpfen die Zellen des waldfrosches
die Eiskristallbildung durch ein
weiteres Frostschutzmittel dass sie
direkt in ihre Membranen einbauen und
sie produzieren eisbindende Kabine die
verhindern dass in kleinen Blutgefäßen
große Kristalle entstehen und das Gewebe
verletzen die Kristallbildung ist aber
nicht das einzige Problem für die Zellen
ein anderes ist der Wasserhaushalt beim
Einfrieren wird den Zellen Wasser
entzogen und das zwischen den Zellen
entstehende Eis scheidet die in dem
Wasser gelösten Stoffe ab dadurch
steigen deren Konzentrationen stark an
und die hohe Glukosekonzentration kommt
da ja noch oben drauf um nicht an diesem
Konzentrationen zu sterben oder in sich
zusammenzufallen produzieren die
Körperzellen zusätzliche Membranproteine
die Aktivstoffe und Wasser in die Zellen
hinein oder aus der Zelle herausbewegen
ein weiteres Problem beim Einfrieren und
Auftauen ganze Organe Tiere und eben
auch Menschen ist auch die Versorgung
der Zellen mit Sauerstoff und
Nährstoffen durch das Blut denn das ist
ja im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes in den
Adern gefroren der nordamerikanische
Waldfrosch sagt deshalb dafür dass er
von außen nach innen einfriert und von
innen nach außen wieder auftaucht
und stellen die wichtigsten Organe ihre
Arbeit zuletzt ein und setzen sie beim
Auftauen als erste wieder fort das
erreicht der Frosch indem er im inneren
Organen wie Herz und Lunge mehr Glukose
herstellt als in äußeren Organen wie
Haut und Skelettmuskeln trotzdem gibt es
noch Momente in denen Organe nicht genug
Sauerstoff und Nährstoffe erhalten hier
dient die Glukose als Energiespender die
Zellen Stellen von dem normalen
Sauerstoff verbrauchende Stoffwechsel
auf einen Glukose verbrauchenden
Stoffwechsel um der praktischerweise
überhaupt keinen Sauerstoff benötigt
außerdem wird der Stoffwechsel
heruntergefahren dabei muss der Frosch
auch mit Antioxidantien verhindern dass
die Zellen programmierten Selbstmord
begehen
zusammengefasst der nordamerikanische
Waldfrosch hat ganz viele ganz spezielle
Adaptionen die verhindern dass seine
Körperzellen beim Einfrieren und
Auftauen Schaden nehmen und ich glaube
das zeigt uns ganz gut wie schwierig es
ist ein ganzes Tier sicher einzufrieren
und wieder aufzutauen und das ist nur so
groß wie mein Daumen das kryonikproblem
ist also hoch komplex
einige Forschungsteams wollen die
Erkenntnisse aus der Grundlagenforschung
am Waldfrosch und anderen Tieren auf die
Kryokonservierung von Spenderorganen
übertragen erste Versuche sehen hier
wohl sehr vielversprechend aus
ob wir jemals Gefahr laufen in eine
kryokammer zu stolpern und 1000 Jahre
später in New York aufzuwachen und ob
wir jemals tiefgefroren nach Alpha
Centauri fliegen können das ist alles
noch unklar der Kryonik steht jedenfalls
noch ein sehr sehr langer Weg bevor denn
Menschen sind bekanntlich keine
nordamerikanischen waldfrösche und haben
all diese hilfreichen Adaptionen nicht
es braucht viel Erfindungsreichtum um
z.B Glukose als Frostschutzmittel
einzusetzen und dabei die negativen
Auswirkungen hoher
glukosekonzentrationen zu vermeiden
aber das Wissen über die kleinen
amphibischen Überlebenskünstler gibt den
Forschenden einige spannende
Ansatzpunkte
ich weiß nicht wie es bei euch ist aber
ich würde mich auf jeden Fall nicht für
die Zukunft einfrieren lassen denn die
Methoden wie sie von den
creolen-instituten heute eingesetzt
werden richten wohl einen so großen
Schaden an Körperzellen und Organen an
dass man den Körper vermutlich nie
reparieren können wird vor allem wenn
etwas schief geht
Patienten Nummer 231 ein 94-jähriger
Texaner wurde im September diesen Jahres
nämlich ganz ohne Frostschutzmittel
eingefroren weil den Institute nicht
rechtzeitig Bescheid gegeben wurde statt
also viel Geld fadenscheinigen
Organisationen zu schenken überlasst es
vielleicht lieber eure Nachkommen
spendet dass der Wissenschaft oder
unterstützt uns auf patreon wie immer
bleibt neugierig danke fürs zuschauen
euer Cedric
der nordamerikanische Waldfrosch